[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm cabby HD here
and this is the week of CES 2018 me out
here
it is raining hi if you've never been to
CES it's definitely a lot there is tech
everywhere people everywhere and just
overall a lot going on here in Las Vegas
but among all that stuff there is some
dope tech buried in there and that's
kind of just been my mission this week
to find it so one of the most buzz
worthy news making things we've seen
this year at CES is razor Project Linda
and razor they tend to get all kinds of
attention at CES for something they're
showing every year this year is this
it's a concept laptop that uses the
razor phone as a brain / trackpad so
this actually isn't a totally new idea
like we've seen smartphone convertibles
into laptops before it's just never
really been wildly successful Razer
hopes to do itbest no of course because
of the razor phone's prowess it's
already an awesome phone with great
speakers so it doesn't have to have
extra speakers and the laptop things
like that doesn't need a processor or
Ram it's just using the razor phone in
fact the only hardware actually in this
Lynda laptop are the RGB keyboard
because of course the battery a webcam
up top and a couple ports the headphone
jack USB C for charging and full size
USB a on the other side for adding
accessories like a mouse bo than that it
just pops the razor phone in and out
with a single button it sits flush it
has the matching color with the Razer
Blade stealth laptop has this little
notch cutout at the front that uses the
fingerprint reader and the power button
from the phone I think the design is
actually pretty well thought out it's
just debatable if this is actually a
practical product or not at all now for
Lynda there is no price range or release
date yet it's a pretty common trend for
stuff we see at CES but I do really like
the design I think it's really
interesting it's just weird to build an
entire accessory like that all around a
smartphone that's probably going to be
updated in a year like in 910 months
when we see you raise your phone to is
this whole laptop people just bought for
their phone
gonna work is compatibility gonna work
do the dimensions stay the stain that
kind of thing
that's a tough I'll keep an eye on that
now I also made it to senators booth and
they were showing exactly one thing that
I was super interested in and it's the
whole reason I went which is Sennheiser
HD 820 so I just showed like the custom
HD eight hundreds I've been using for a
while bison eyes are in my last video
the set up tour but these will allegedly
take that to a new level by isolating
sound with the glass over the back of
the ear clubs you can see it it's this
concave Gorilla Glass so basically they
retain a lot of the characteristics of
open-back headphones like the HD 800 s
that big drivers the open nature of it
the wide soundstage
but it now seals you off from the noise
on the outside of your environment for
people who don't want to hear all that
so this I am definitely interested in I
was able to listen to them for a bit I
can confirm they sounded incredible but
yeah I'd love to actually get these into
the studio and put them to work they
look incredible they will be selling
these and they will be expensive I'm
thinking two to three thousand dollars
super expensive headphones and then over
in a hotel near the strip I also found
HTC's set up pretty interesting where
they're showing some new announcements
to HTC vive la do you might not know
I've used the vive headset a lot we have
one in the studio and they announced two
pretty important things one is they now
make a vive pro which is this all built
into one headset with headphones and the
strap over the top a high resolution
display inside better tracking basically
it's a much improved VR experience for
those who want the best of the best you
can also still buy the regular original
HTC vive but then number two they showed
an HTC vive wireless adapter which sort
of looks like this
bug antenna on your head that plugs into
the headset but this is a game-changer
because it tracks just as well but now
allows you to walk around completely
untethered from your computer normally
you're plugged into your computer and
you just kind of happen to hope you're
not tripping over all the cables when
you turn around and things like that
with this basically you just have to
plug into a battery plus it in your
pocket and it'll last a couple hours
with something like this a small three
thousand milliamp power battery but
obviously you can plug into something a
bit bigger if you're gonna be gaming for
a longer time so that was pretty cool I
think people who use the vive will find
that wireless adapter pretty great you
can use the wireless adapter with the
old five or the new vive Pro also I'm
aware that using their
screen set for that kind of opens people
up to mess with the footage but I guess
too late to change that all right some
other things
razor also at their booth head this
pretty ridiculous looking pair of
desktop speakers and a subwoofer they
look pretty badass they of course had
RGB again at the base because you know
RGB but I have no idea how good they
sound because it's way too noisy on the
show floor but I'll be interested in
checking those out Audio Technica also
brought a lot of new stuff that like 10
new pairs of headphones and their booth
some gaming headsets I'm open back some
of these Wireless noise cancelling
headphones that look like they're aiming
to rival the Bose QuietComfort series
then they also let me try out their
top-of-the-line ATX 5000 so $2,000
open-back headphones and don't get me
wrong they sound great but they're open
back so I'm on the show floor where it's
super noisy suppose there's no way I can
fully appreciate them quite yet but
pretty much all of these are going on
sale soon if they haven't started
already there's also tons and tons of
drones at CES one weird when I didn't
expect was in a Yamaha booth it was
massive it looked about the size of like
three people put together I know about
zero other information about this drone
other than it looked really cool look
like they can go about 200 miles an hour
but that's just me looking at it but
what was really cool in their booth is
this which is a self-balancing
motorcycle which didn't really impress
me at first when I first saw it until I
realized those side wheels aren't
touching the ground
this bike is completely standing on its
own on two wheels and that guy is
pushing it around and it's just kind of
responding by shifting its weight and
staying upright that was a pretty cool
demo but speaking of those drones DJ
eyes booth also had some pretty cool
stuff as they usually do including their
Osmo mobile - it's a much cheaper
stabilization than the original Osmo
something like 50 60 70 bucks cheaper
than the original super lightweight but
it still does pretty much all the same
stuff smart phone control a nice handle
a grip for video or an emotes start/stop
I can see a lot of people picking this
up and this is of course also actually
going on sale but so far in the first
day I've been here that is what I've
seen that looks pretty cool but
literally as I'm uploading this I'm
probably literally
back to the show floor to check out some
more stuff so if you see cool stuff that
you think is worth showing on video or
checking out or exploring hit me up on
Twitter
send me the link if you're on the
subreddit send it there too I'm checking
that now and that's pretty much it see
you guys back out in vase thanks for
watching catch you in part 2 talk to you
the next one please